it's gonna be a good day
the church of what's happening now is
presented by on it
the days are back the church of what's
happening now is proud to introduce you
to hellotushy.com hellotushy.com makes
portable devices that spray your butt
clean with water go to hellotushy.com
church right now to get 10 off that's
hellotushy.com
church
oh [ __ ]
here we go [ __ ]
[Music]
this is donald trump's favorite song
what
come on what this is what he hears in
the white house every night
this is what the obama's left from time
to get there
here you go [ __ ]
the church of what's happening now
wednesday
february 8th
who's better than you
kick that horse lee
come on
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
and you thought this was just a podcast
huh this is a [ __ ] party wagon
here we go black people jump up and down
come on black people mexicans jump up
and down let's go
armenians do your thing
for jungle wiggle [ __ ] sucker wiggle
here we go the intensity
oh [ __ ]
there's a white chick sucked black dixon
in the 70s [ __ ] yeah well here we go
[Music]
ralphie
oh [ __ ] and uncle joey
[Music]
my family what the [ __ ]
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle joey here the church of what's
happening now it's a beautiful
[ __ ] night i'm happy you get to
join us
lisa and yes
again my brother mr ralphie may hi
everybody if he's in town we bump
[ __ ] ralphie man i had to tell
somebody today something happened
the [ __ ] studio burnt down i'll call
you next week what do i give a [ __ ]
somehow i'm sure i got blamed oh you
always get the blame ah
i always throw leo flying right under
the bus
put water on the computer and get people
over there and [ __ ]
i'm sorry about the periscope this
morning what happened was this let me
explain to you what i the hell i lived
in okay
joe rogan's my brother i love him to
death but he gets a lot of creepy
[ __ ] people
that listen to him and the creepy people
but when they can't get through the hymn
they start going down the line so they
go to duncan when duncan tells them to
[ __ ] off they go to ahri when ari tells
them to [ __ ] off they'll come to me when
i turn the [ __ ] off they'll go to brian
when brian tells him to [ __ ] off they'll
go to tony hinchcliffe when tony hinch
goes don't go to sarah tiana and it's on
and onward and onward
so this started two three weeks ago in
cleveland i had to fly in early the
night before right
i get there my [ __ ] sleep apnea
machine breaks
at six o'clock at night i gotta get a
new [ __ ] wire what am i gonna get so
already i go in the panic moment i got
radio on thursday morning i gotta be
alert i can't i'm not gonna go to
[ __ ] season let me not deal with this
let me get something to eat with these
dudes from la that wanted to play with
me that i know him
and i'll come back and i'll deal with
this [ __ ] i'll figure it out i'll scotch
tape it i'll do something you know right
i go i eat with these two guys it's cold
out they walk me back into the hotel you
know the whole town cleveland where you
stay on the corner
from i walk in and there's these two
people there i don't think about nothing
you know i just see two people there
that's what my job is
i'm talking to these two guys and all of
a sudden they're looking over at us
and they keep looking and looking and
looking and as soon as and i i try to i
go there here for a [ __ ] picture god
damn it i know
and next thing you know i go real loud i
go listen my sleep apnea machine broke
to the guys i go let me go upstairs and
deal with this i turn around the guy
chases me with the girl they come up to
me like listen listen listen listen we
got your present
but it's in our car
right away that's not going to happen
right we didn't know if we'd see you or
not but listen
i'm not walking to no car you coming to
the show would you like me to leave you
tickets for the show that's nice yes we
would i mean that's how fast it was i'm
in a rush guy yeah i got to go figure
out the sleep apnea [ __ ] thing so do
you want tickets for the show we took a
picture and while we're taking the
picture that's when he starts to [ __ ]
the guy
by [ __ ] uh going to [ __ ] some
country the jungle of amazon and doing
[ __ ] ayahuasca
and all this [ __ ] that i don't know
anyway i don't need to hear this [ __ ]
this is not for me you want to take a
chance go to the bronx and get a three
dollar bag of heroin you don't need to
go all the way to [ __ ] br but
for
what el you know
listen before you move to la you see how
these [ __ ] idiots work did you but
you're watching tv
and you're trying to lose weight and
you're working real hard you're doing
jumping jacks and also some hollywood
guy comes on he goes i have a new
revolutionary way to lose weight
we do this these [ __ ] always
got the next answer well guess what i'm
from the 70s [ __ ] that wasn't the
answer
that was the answer you [ __ ]
are stealing living off the 70s every tv
show every [ __ ] movie you guys are
living off the [ __ ] 70s okay so when
i see all it's like quaaludes quaaludes
were great they became ecstasy yeah
that's what happens they become ecstasy
but it's the same cousin for the [ __ ]
quail it's the same thing that just
evolved me
listen you want the answer take a hit
acid when my mother was dead
three four months how do you think i
recovered from the pain i get asked it
every [ __ ] night and that breaks down
whatever problem you have you don't need
to go to ayahuasca in the jungle and
have a shaman around your breathing
stinky dirty yeah all you need is a
three dollar hit of some good [ __ ]
window pain you put on black sabbath
[ __ ] sad bloody sabbath the answer to
your questions will come to you i don't
care if you put the beatles help on the
answers to your questions will come to
you i'm telling you this as a man
because this is what i did for [ __ ]
years when i was recovering off the
biggest pain you could possibly have and
you're about to die
so don't [ __ ] tell me my [ __ ] job
okay this this and i'm gonna tell you in
front of somebody just so you guys know
and he's gonna tell you this november
i'm gonna be cleaning off coke for 10
years ralphie i know 10 [ __ ] years
can you believe that [ __ ] yes did i go
to get robin gained did i go to brazil
no should i go get hugs did i go to
rehab no i need to go to [ __ ] aaa and
get out you know all these people in l.a
go to aaa they get clean yeah but two
weeks later they go to a doctor they
give him a stretch of pills yeah and
also they have all these symptoms these
fake [ __ ] symptoms and they're giving
you pills so you you're just drugged up
on pills but you're still going to
people telling them when you're on a.a
yeah yeah and not for nothing i was
there the last night
you had a great [ __ ] run and that was
a great last night to go out on i had a
great [ __ ] that was a great [ __ ]
night 27 year run on [ __ ] blow yeah
but i was there at the [ __ ] finish
line dude let me dude you smoked an
ounce of mine [ __ ] matzo g weed an
ounce okay after eating like four
dinners it was terrific food all right
and we're laughing our butts off and
then i bring out mushrooms a little
after after dinner [ __ ] get you
started let the day go let's remember
the indians natives oh
all right and we put it out there
remember what happened i love the
indians are you kidding me don't bring
the [ __ ] indians up i love them the
last time you brought indians up you got
to do benefits i asked
no i know i sent that kid to camp space
camp i'm [ __ ] i'm helping out at
natives i'm [ __ ] saving them
somebody's got to do it
anyway listen to this garbage i i we we
did i bring out an ounce of of [ __ ]
great mushrooms hawaiian ones have you
ever had the hawaiian ones i don't know
you have to ask him okay the the the
regular ones are a little bit bigger the
hawaiians are smaller and the caps
thicker all right and i brought out a
[ __ ] ounce of the most deadly [ __ ]
mushrooms on the planet
coco
ate half an ounce of mushrooms
okay
half an ounce do you understand me on
top of smoking because it was
thanksgiving and he was goddamn thankful
all right he did all of that over the
course of like six hours okay and then
then went to the comedy store and got a
set a la theovan
and the [ __ ] lights in there were
turning purple the whole original room
was purple and i'm in there telling
jokes on stage oh my god i was the only
one in the room i couldn't even see the
audience members i got in my [ __ ] car
so funny and i got the [ __ ] out of there
but ten
years with no drama
no oh my god i feel like doing bro i'm
gonna read what's that what's the word
they use i'm gonna
i'm gonna re relapse relapse
i don't want this poor girl i'm with to
find me on the floor dead i don't want
her to walk out of the bedroom and see
fat little legs in the kitchen
turn them purple because i want to do
blow in front of it i can't do it no
more
and that's pretty much the [ __ ] end
of it dude that was really [ __ ] man but
it's like we had so much drama to
getting high uh like i like to just roll
a joint no no you gotta roll the joint
and cut a matchbook and put a filter
what filter are you talking about what
filter are you talk a matchbook cover
you got to be cool everybody wants to be
[ __ ] cool i'm through with cool right
i didn't play that game where i'm from
they didn't play the cool game you were
just [ __ ] either you were cool or you
didn't nobody teaches you you putting on
a t-shirt doesn't make you cool no you
putting a goatee and shaving it real
tight you know like a [ __ ] half a [ __ ]
that don't make you [ __ ]
cool you know what i'm saying but it
does take on my boss yes thank you
but everybody in l.a wants to be cool
hold on i'm gonna go to mexico city i
haven't talked to that that's how you
walk shut the [ __ ] up
just take it listen if you're not gonna
do a hit ass it'll take a three dollar
bag of heroin just leave me the [ __ ]
alone it's not my world
it's not my world i don't even want to
listen to that kind of talk i never did
there's a reason people are just hearing
about it now it's [ __ ] stupid i know
it's it's and listen it helps people
with opiate predictions and it helps all
these type of people and [ __ ] like this
take it to somebody else all right yeah
i'm an old school type of [ __ ] guy
and that's the way i'm going to go out
that's it lee and me have conversations
every night and lee looks at me because
he knows i don't give a [ __ ]
i i don't know what you're talking about
you want an adventure go to the boogie
down bronx i'll surround you with 20
black guys and three puerto ricans and
that's an adventure right there you
don't need to make to you can tell your
friends at starbucks i went to brazil oh
my god you're so
you're so strong and valiant shut the
[ __ ] up go [ __ ] you the same people that
are gonna go to canada when [ __ ] uh
trump became president you know man it's
a sick dog it gets old man no [ __ ]
[ __ ] old i come from a different
[ __ ] society of people and men act
like men
you know every night i turned the
[ __ ] tv on tonight they're protesting
again uh how many times i'm gonna tell
you there's no future
in protesting there's nothing there's no
future people you guys learn how to
[ __ ] they go down there they're [ __ ]
with a hole in their chest just do drugs
like i did
you don't have to mingle and to be cool
so people go oh my god
you're marching
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you i got better things to do with
my time yeah it's more life yeah you're
creating traffic i know you don't like
trump but go [ __ ] yourself
you're [ __ ] making traffic you [ __ ] i
hope you fall get aids in your mouth
[ __ ] you all right they're a bunch of
dicks okay i got stuck in one of that
goddamn woman march and i didn't know
why they were bitching okay all right
you don't like trump hey you guess what
maybe you should have moished your ass
to the [ __ ] uh voting booth all right
because he told you three weeks before
hey i'm gonna grab you by the [ __ ] and
you know what most of america was like
i'm cool with that that's all right i
can overlook that nobody likes [ __ ]
trump everybody's mad at [ __ ] trump
yeah
they should have done something when
they had the shot
okay you know what bitching me about
being a democrat is [ __ ] you you have
until the end of the game to win the
[ __ ] game coco you have until the end
the [ __ ] last play all right like
[ __ ] new england
yeah new england on sunday you thought
it was over no we got overtime now we're
gonna settle it okay all right and
instead all right these [ __ ] these
little [ __ ] democrat [ __ ] are all
[ __ ] crying
i want a recount i want a [ __ ]
recount i want to get to electoral
college not to do this
you lose on sunday you don't wake up
nobody from the falcons woke up on on
monday and go man
you know everybody i know we lost
yesterday and the biggest you know
[ __ ] choke you could ever lose all
right but we really wanted to win
so
uh now if everybody just agrees that
we'll just say that we won that's cool
right that's cool it's cool that we won
the super bowl even though new england
won but we really want you know what i
mean it's like you [ __ ] i don't give
a [ __ ] of
referee valerie putin blew the [ __ ]
car i don't give a [ __ ]
you [ __ ] lost you lost you know what
bro the way i look at this
they had bernie sanders
they had joe biden a man you had bernie
sanders but you drank the [ __ ] juice
of being cool
a woman president you just up and down
like a [ __ ] momo that you're right
you know you fooled the country one time
and i'm not saying
fooled the country
but obama was one of those weird
presidencies it wasn't gonna happen
twice bro
you know the who said it best we won't
get fooled again
yeah we won't get fooled again with the
[ __ ] smoking mirrors and the priuses
and the you know i know people who were
buying clothes
to go to hillary party clinton parties
oh yeah on the west side like that's how
[ __ ] embarrassing it got like
i never had to sit there and watch that
[ __ ] teleprompter you know me i don't
give a [ __ ] and i think we were doing a
podcast yeah we were yeah with uh
tutorial with tutorial yeah we're doing
a [ __ ] box oh man a little nicky yeah
we didn't get oh man you didn't give a
[ __ ] two dicks about nothing man
you know if you know how hard we've
worked in our lives and what we went
through
there wasn't a president there to help
us no [ __ ] time
i love
when i was [ __ ] i still remember when
i got thrown out of the benders it was a
day [ __ ] reagan got shot yeah do you
think when he was laying down on the
floor he goes hold on joey i got a place
for you to move to yes [ __ ] no right you
can [ __ ] reach
in fact that's why i learned about
bureaucracy was when my mother died
that's when i really learned yeah right
what this country's all about it's we're
going to give you your money but you
gotta do 82 papers by the time it's like
what they do to you now when you call
sprint yeah to tell them that you have a
bill problem they put you on hold so
long you just hang up and pay your 40
dollars
like time is worth you know what i'm
saying with bureaucracy when my mother
died go down there i had to go down
every other week oh you have to bring
the mortgage from that i'm [ __ ] 16.
who's got the mortgage book from the
[ __ ] house my mother's dead what
mortgage book every week it was like
more and more [ __ ] and i was taking a
bus out to newark
sometimes i get a ride but most of the
times i take a bus at three o'clock in
the afternoon and come back at seven
eight o'clock at night i learned about
bureaucracy and our government the hard
[ __ ] way yeah because when you need
something it's i gotta fill out
paperwork and more paperwork and come
back three weeks from thursday
you know it's like you get hurt on the
job it takes you three weeks for your
disability to kick in
most american families they can't wait
three weeks don't have [ __ ] through
no not at all they ain't got [ __ ]
three [ __ ] three weeks
you know other things are [ __ ] by the
way everything dude that's why take
smoke your week that's why i took the
place at harris i got offered a bigger
place that would have to charge more for
tickets and and and and i said no
my fans can't do that and i won't do
that to them okay you want to [ __ ] go
pay 120
and laugh at [ __ ] sock jokes from j
seinfeld hey there it is if you want 35
me banging you in the face and talking
about tea bagging [ __ ]
i got you covered i'll give you way more
[ __ ] laughs than he will but if you
want to spend that money it's there but
man my fans are coming from everywhere
dude
though the church people you guys are
[ __ ] showing up like nobody's
business they're savages they like
nobody's business they drive they get
vikings dude
they go
and and they're coming out and because
of all the love you've shown me my first
two weeks church we're gonna do a
giveaway all right where we uh
we'll i'll be talking delay let's
[ __ ] get all of you [ __ ] the real
deal
[ __ ] okay all right the and and
we and
you [ __ ] went you start tweeting
about me and mad flavor and the flying
jew
tammy's the official winner she's the
first winner oh yeah yeah uh oogie's
working spooky oh yeah yeah yeah she's
already she's already [ __ ] done she's
good to go she's yeah she's just she's
good she's one that's no problem but we
gotta get we're gonna have to get some
more got larry out there just
cultivating he hasn't even gone through
the show well noble d i'm bringing okay
so i'm bringing darren from that okay
yeah from colorado so i got that party
going all right i'm going to bring
george out under the auspices that it
might be a sports show
of course george from [ __ ] jersey
he going nowhere right i know he's got a
girl he's got this sort of thing go [ __ ]
yourself george hey bring me the chicken
fried cheesy lemon fried cheesy pizza
and just keep it like that i don't think
he goes there no more what how can i go
there the chicken franchisee pizza yeah
it's okay did you guys see what yellow
romero put up today it it i must have
laughed for 10 minutes
what is it what is it so is biz being
fighting him or not that i think it's
the next fight i don't know if it's
fully been announced yet but i i guess
it's i guess
tomorrow night
oh
yeah oh yeah and i love i know you love
bisping i love mike i love bisping too
but just
like that i love trash talk so just he
made a gofundme page for his his future
medical bills
and who uh i have nothing against mike i
like mike but it's just it's just funny
it's so [ __ ] funny that mma is
getting [ __ ] funnier and [ __ ]
funnier my [ __ ] irish brother conor
mcgregor suck my big irish balls oh
crying
i i like i want that on my phone i want
t-shirts i want that everything suck my
big irish balls
[ __ ] yeah who knew who knew we had a
church in an island okay
me and you has anything been going on
when i don't even know what's going on
with mma the last two weeks i haven't
even seen that oh my god i saw that
today today and i said wow that's the
first time i've seen anything on mma
yeah that's all
there's a fight this week yeah it's
brooklyn that's anderson silva i i place
money on him nobody even knows nothing
like nobody said nothing to me nobody's
called that's why i didn't know i'm like
what the [ __ ] going on whatever man i
lost and i seen the [ __ ] thing today
and i go wait a second there's a fight
this weekend yeah nobody's talking about
this [ __ ] fight
brooklyn new york
i haven't heard one [ __ ] thing i i
don't know what to be a better fight the
one in the ring and the octagon are the
ones with the people leaving okay
because that's going to be a great fight
right outside all these guys get all
[ __ ] up on red bull and brooklyn who's
going to go to this thing it's not going
to be your typical brooklynites it's
going to be those tickets are going to
be high oh yeah they're doing it up
there because they could charge a little
more that's that's jay-z's neighborhood
[ __ ] right you're right so it's not the
brooklyn now we left 30 years ago with
knuckleheads hitting each other and [ __ ]
it's a new civilized brooklyn where
they're probably gonna
bring you know stevia soda
and then to drink and
nobody smokes by you if you like a joint
at one of those things now they look at
you like if you're hitler yeah did you
know that man
especially in new york i can't believe
it i grew up in new york
i used to smoke everywhere in new york
like you might have joined now in new
york
people walk on the other side of the
street they look at you like you take
pictures of you on their [ __ ] phones
it is crazy
there's a lot of cities i go and i
travel people get mad at me you don't
periscope listen guys it ain't the same
and ain't the same i know you can
periscope but i know what you can't yeah
there's some places you can sit behind
outside and smoke a joint i put the
[ __ ]
the phone on a fence and nobody sees me
there's some places
they're watching you stick out like a
[ __ ] sore thumb they're watching you
man yeah man what's the matter lee
nothing's that matter you're really
going through changes i started the
sweat starting
oh my god it's uh
what do you mean it's sweat starting
it's just um
i don't know what it is i don't know it
does it make you sweat too i don't know
what what what are you talking about
this the sugar cubes make you sweat it's
sugar it's not what's in it it's not the
sugar cubes it's not the sugar it's
what's in the [ __ ] sugar cubes
that makes you sweat oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
look at your fingers are they getting
all wavy not yet the whole fingers
aren't going baby but everything i'm
gonna do your favorite my daughter she
made this for me and i'm gonna wear it
all right i just want you to look at
that every now and then okay
it's gonna be a safe place for you all
right lee thank you all right if you
need to look at anything you know look
at that focus on the focus on the yellow
okay just find me the yellow one all
right i got these when you were a kid
and people spoke about acid what did you
think no like i
it's not even that i was scared what
drugs were people talking about when you
were 18 in high school uh [ __ ] weed
and drinking and maybe some pills and i
don't know i was a nerd so maybe they
were doing and i just wasn't invited but
i didn't see [ __ ] i didn't see any of
this and maybe some maybe some mushrooms
in boston i think some ecstasy ecstasy
yeah ah ecstasy coke pills yeah i didn't
even see my i didn't see cocktail got
out here
where'd you see coke out here the first
time uh party of a guy i worked with
he just and i didn't even really see it
i saw them in the in the room
pudding and that's
that's why i told you the only reason i
have a volkswagen is because i like this
key i like then
and it's uh this is the key they were
using
i was like 22 or something oh they're
doing key bumps on that yeah yeah little
volkswagen key thing
and it's uh
um
yeah that was mostly just that i never
really
i think
my introduction to like psychedelics is
the podcast with like you you talking
about it rogan talking about i've never
even dreamed of it let me tell you
at 12 we were we were [ __ ]
doing mushrooms
every weekend
every weekend in clexville arkansas all
right boy scout camp didn't [ __ ]
matter uh [ __ ] anything camping deer
hunting fight didn't matter [ __ ]
shrooms were on the menu they're
everywhere everywhere everywhere
everybody
cal pass just everybody you just go pick
came from dry so you don't get mailed
out all right and don't you're done okay
and then we get then there was like the
creepy guys who were like over the 21
who were always trying to [ __ ] our high
school girls who had parties like the
red cup party bonfires and that's when i
first smoked a joint was there at that
party uh my buddy uh joel uh joe god
damn it i forget joe was cool
[ __ ] he had long hair hippie
[ __ ] dad was a vietnam vet uh
joe penny i knew i'd get it joe penny
roll and rolling [ __ ] pinners that's
where i thought that that name came from
the little pinner joints was from joe
penny because he wrote little joints all
right and he saw me because i that guy
that guy wouldn't he thought i didn't
pay for my red cup and i'm like you dumb
i was a wise ass i was like you [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ] like i'm just walking around
the woods with a big red cup and oh i
just happened to [ __ ] bump into you
you [ __ ] dummy all right and he
wouldn't [ __ ] give me any beer and
[ __ ] [ __ ] so joe saw it and
then when we were leaving by the way i
smoked i thought
he was like this is marijuana
is it gonna kill me he's like no and he
was right coco he was [ __ ] right jack
i i smoked five joints that night or
that mexican dirt weed okay we even
played that game where you where you
load up one joint with a big ass seed
and everybody takes a joint we all power
smoke until the seed blows up
blows your face like those old cigars
that's the greatest sweet game nobody
can play it now because there's no
[ __ ]
seats in the feed all right and uh
we did mushrooms that and uh and you'd
always save up your money for uh for
wine cooters so you could try to finger
bang girls all right that was our
[ __ ] move finger banging the chicks
with the bar bartles and james mountain
barry was the
ah
that's what it is
oh you are getting sweaty lately oh dawg
it's all my girlfriend please he's going
to have a hot dog oh my god you're all
right oh yeah i'm fine for now i'm
drinking you're having a panic attack
too so breathe out of your nose
i'm not having a panic attack
while you're on the twitter right there
hey cause i'm not on mine i put it on to
uh um
uh put it on uh it add me to the to the
full thing so people can see this about
the church because i didn't know the
church's twitter handle
all right and and ben before you get too
[ __ ] up uh text aaron to to re send it
out
okay yeah out the ass
i want everybody to know because i want
all my fans if you ain't down with the
church you need to be
okay all right
that's that's number one all right you
got to get down with the church i and
number two i want i want everybody to
have more chances to win a free vacation
uh to come to [ __ ] las vegas nevada
jack
all right and we'll have a [ __ ] blast
i like it i like it anxiety you're all
right oh
it's uh
just breathe out of your nose okay
another cheeba chew drink no it really
hasn't started kicking in yet and it
really hasn't so what are you sweating
from because it it that's the point
that's kind of society if you're you're
thinking about it
i'm not thinking about it though no i
could see it in your face
he's thinking about it i'm not thinking
it's just i just don't sweat your face
is so [ __ ] red shut up yeah you're
not thinking about it you're thinking
about it you sit there and you [ __ ]
boil in it until you know
yeah that's why you get bad chips dude i
really i swear was the last time you
looked at the yellow look at the yellow
look at this on the [ __ ] yellow all
right don't
look at the [ __ ] yellow line look at
the yellow there you go
all right good man there's a little
sugar nice i know he's already [ __ ]
yeah he's doing it how's every shirt i
have a sugar night shirt because come on
that's your street name sugar white
okay
he's bad he's bad
so who else is on this trip over there
on friday night today man um
no
no dude i think i'm the first one to
have uh george wallace isn't invaded
george wallace isn't there anymore
they've got that piece of [ __ ]
vinnie favorito uh has got some of the
orleans or something i don't even know
where his [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] ass is
that guy's the worst [ __ ] human ever
to get behind a microphone and call
himself a comedian i hope he gets three
types of cancer in his ass and his mouth
not the fast kind the slow kind so they
think they can cure it all right he's a
[ __ ] pestilence on [ __ ] humanity
i'm sorry i'm sorry
i get overhated about that benny
favorite it's a piece of [ __ ] all right
he paid his dues he paid his [ __ ]
he didn't pay his [ __ ] bookies i'll
tell you that [ __ ] guy who else is on
bets too
hey
[ __ ] and people are taking action for
him still you dumb [ __ ] okay how about
ask all those boston comics who got
[ __ ] out all that money he [ __ ] them
off with all right it's a teacher comedy
class dumb suckers they should have
known you either have it or you don't
you don't go to class you don't go to
the club focus on the yellow focus on
this is on the yellow
now you see it right
i i can feel it i'm not freaking out
though i can feel the kick it's
definitely kicking in i like it i like
ass i'm not like it's just i sweat
yellow
yellow yellow just yellow baby by yellow
that time that's all i'm thinking about
other colors just yellow
that's it i like it oh yeah that's my
favorite color stay in the mix stay in
the zone baby
oh okay
it's funny though when i got into comedy
especially when i came out here i go how
long is it going to take
for me to [ __ ] up like how long was it
going to take for me to
hit somebody with a chair or
rob one of these comedy clubs you know
because you could just sit there and
look at ten thousand for so long for so
long before you have to smack those
little [ __ ] mama me if it was anybody
else's wedding oh oh you know it's like
if they only knew if
they knew
you know it's like it's like it's so
crazy how you we sit here and we [ __ ]
around
and you crack jokes but how sad is it
that like
keith richards i live [ __ ] whitney
houston oh yeah like like ozzy
osbourne's outliving everybody
and he's still doing blowing pills she's
trying to dump him two months ago
because he was still getting [ __ ]
high and [ __ ] the hairdresser how old
is this guy
they don't stop
what people don't realize is i just
figured this out too me and my my tour
manager ben we were talking about this
how the [ __ ] can
ozzy you not understand a goddamn word
he says
but but sings like a [ __ ] bird how
the [ __ ] did that ever happen
lou graham there's the english people
that's what they do they're [ __ ] bad
lebron jack i'm sorry i'll cut you off
no no i'm just thinking about how these
p you know i
i sit here and i go how the [ __ ] did i
outlive whitney houston
like especially during the martel cartel
deck yeah and i always felt bad like
i i never knew
when the trust was gonna end like i
never knew at what point i didn't know
if it was gonna be being on the road
with mark babbitt one day
you know
and him being no no because when i do it
i heard he's lost lst yeah when i first
moved here he used to uh book these
shows
with carlos and uh and uh
when what's his name was still very hot
what's the mexican guy the you know the
paul rodriguez and he was born george
lopez george lopez i mean that was
mark babbitt mark babbitt was driving
back to texas
with 30 40 g in cash
yeah because he was like he would take
the money from the safe
at the last stop
and use it to finance
his tours
she was at a millionaire she's somewhere
is she still alive no no no the he he
bought it i mean he didn't buy it he
didn't buy it
it was it was an old lady who owned
no no no you're thinking of uh
of the austin woman right what was the
name of the lady in boston because pete
was his stepson or something yeah yeah
right
and um uh she was uh she owned a bunch
of country bars
but she just thought it was a good
manager and her gi bottas she bought it
from um
uh the uh sandy marcus okay and sandy
and her husbands are the ones who
started the last stop and then sandy
sold it when she wanted to get out to
this uh lady who was a
multi-multi-millionaire probably worth
probably 150 million dollars more
because she owned like the men's club
she owned the biggest country bars she
had a majority of steak and gillies when
gillies was hot and [ __ ] the urban
cowboy this this woman had so much
[ __ ] money and this was just one of
her things
that she liked comedy but she wouldn't
even come in and that's how she got peed
in there but before pete man with three
hands mark babbitt was taking money out
of that place so he was taking the money
out of the bank and then he was pulling
what i was doing as a kid you borrowed
25 grand on friday
as long as you have it back monday
before the bank opens
you went back 30 grand
like i said i had a friend who
worked at a bank
in the early 80s
that was the deal
friday at three monday at nine he better
have my money to put back in that
[ __ ] bank vault
but i'm getting five grand off the top
and he did it every [ __ ] week this
kid yeah but he could never be light on
a monday he
only wow
you couldn't do that now no no [ __ ]
way no no [ __ ] way you can do that
now let me tell you how good they had it
wired
this kid that i'm talking about in
particular
i knew him i grew up with him and one
time when my mom died he worked at a
bank
and i was telling his younger brother i
got these checks i got this credit card
he goes talk to my brother
talk to my brother so i called the
brother i met him
i gained the two checks the credit cards
he calls me two days later he's gonna
meet me at nix
so it's you know my mother just died
they had just shot john lennon
oh wow it was just the week when they
shot john lynn like they shot john on a
monday night football yeah during monday
night football i picked up that envelope
on tuesday
like i gave him those checks on saturday
yeah and the next day when i was in
school his brother came up to me and
said call my brother he wants to talk to
you about something i call him he goes
meet me up at next eight o'clock i went
up there he gave me an envelope that was
four inches deep
all [ __ ] bills were a hundred dollars
my mom was dead but will this take care
of things for a while
forever
forever
i got i got that money and i put on the
mic i moved in with this family and i
moved on and i put the money under my
underwear
and they would never [ __ ] know i
would just
it was like it was like a real atm
machine
like i hid my jeans on top of it yeah
and i would just dip my hand on there
and take 100 billion go out at night
that's how small that was like at that
point and you never thought about saving
any of it oh yeah oh yeah i thought
about saving it and yeah investing
yeah i was 17 years old yeah yeah okay
yeah i'm going to invest in what
getting them [ __ ]
yeah gabby that's what i'm investingly
there's no investments lead you took
that you took that to the bar and you
invested it you you wouldn't hear
something before [ __ ] up lee sure is
it is that not only did he just say oh
that was fine he was still working all
right him and his buddies they would
they would drop out of trees on
unsuspecting gay guys and beat them like
gorillas till one flag
unsuspecting gay guys they were
perverts perverts and pedophiles they
did not know
what
my friend just went to
my friend just went to my friend just
went to the mayor's
to my buddy's ball yeah he's done
my friend just went to my buddy's ball
on friday veneri yeah had his first ball
on friday 175 dollars a ticket oh wow
why does he have a ball like for his
life because he's a commissioner oh he's
an assemblyman i love it and uh he told
me that the guy we used for bait as kids
was dead i go how does he look he goes
bro
that dude hasn't aged a [ __ ] day he
said he still looks like an italian
model oh wow we used to take this kid
and
the reason why we used them is because
he had a connection
i know that if we ever got arrested this
[ __ ] would get squashed at the end
right before they really press charges
this kid had too much juice right that's
the reason why he used to take him i'd
split right 50 50 right down the middle
but all he had to do was just bait
that's all we had to do was just bait we
did the [ __ ] kicking and the pulling
all right so so explain to him okay so
he'd be out there and then horrible
horrible
dark
fun time
do you ever say that did you ever say
that to yourself
like someday when you guys would be 50
go that was a terrible
horrible
fun time in my life
it was that dark and terrible like it
was like if i think about it now it was
dark
like even the daytime it was dark like
there was no sunlight in my life then
and it was my it was like my junior year
it started my sophomore summer going
into junior year
where you heard rumblings there was this
davey thomas this thomas family and they
were the kings of it the family who
owned wendy's stay with me
and they were the first ones that 64th
street crew were the first ones that
started going to
boulevard east and then the words
started getting out you can make some
money
you know how people drive lyft now oh
yeah right that's how it was then yeah
that's the money going to boulevard east
at night oh my god like that's how
[ __ ] it was so well a spare change
you know what's crazy when i read when i
read the iceman's book
when i read the iceman's book yeah oh my
god the iceman used to live in west new
york new jersey
and he said that in the 60s he would
just kill people for practice
on boulevard east
get the book get the [ __ ] book
he goes i can't he goes i really
couldn't give an actual account of how
many people i killed
because there was three years i was just
practicing
he goes i'd go to a bar on the west side
yeah and tell a guy i was gay or
whatever and he'd follow me to jersey
and i'd kill him on the jersey side and
[ __ ] he goes just for practice just to
practice control tactics oh my god this
guy was the real [ __ ] deal why do you
read this book this book sounds like a
terrible no it's fascinating it was very
fascinating let me tell you something
why do you look at tigers in dessert
when the iceman popped up 10 15 years
ago like people called you the next day
yeah it was [ __ ] disturbing yeah it
was disturbing like even the first time
i watched i'm like because you live near
him or just no no no no it was
disturbing that
i always thought that you kicked
somebody in the stomach and you had some
fun and you called them a [ __ ]
this guy had it too
this guy had it to a complete different
level what was he doing
he was a hitman that
i forget the whole [ __ ] story he was
working on a porno thing
editing films and the guy wouldn't pay
him
and uh and uh he [ __ ] whacked him
and then and
his brother raped the 12 year old girl
oh man i killed her and then he threw
the girl off the roof i mean the whole
family's rotten oh my god the family was
rocked to the core
when i when you read the book there's
times you're reading the book you have
to shut the book and go right why am i
reading oh my god his first wife dumped
him and he cut his nipples off yeah i
remember you told me that story he cut a
nip as well yeah and he used to he used
to live right there
with a coat factory when we were kids
that was it we weren't buying the coal
fire if you go to the coat factory today
and vacuum it you're gonna find rocks or
coke from the 80s until i i'm i wish i
was kid it was every night you knew that
if you were going to come over and you
wanted to get coke and you was coming
from the city go to the coat factory
there'd be four cars there and somebody
in that car had blow some
behind a tree
behind the dumpster somewhere in this
area there's an ounce of [ __ ] coke
wow
yeah that the first interview with the
iceman was very fascinating what
happened was leaf that people took that
interview sucked it in
and then started hearing other things
and also and put them together
and they were all really tied together
oh like different stories oh no all the
mafia hits were tied through him
he began doing uh hits for one family
and then he kept going to different
families and yeah he would play for
different captains and nobody knew what
the [ __ ] he was doing
then he got really crazy the third phase
of it is he got really crazy and he
started saying that he was there on
every murder like when kelly got shot i
was up the corner yeah right
when uh the guy from the [ __ ] bananas
got shot at joe mary's restaurant in
brooklyn and that summer he says he had
one of the tables that he was one of the
backup shooters
if the original shoot is [ __ ] up
that's a lie you know what i'm saying
yeah these
that was an inner family thing they
weren't going to get a [ __ ] pollock
to step in on that one there was just a
lot of things he claimed but at the end
he said something that i've said on here
you know all these people like
conspiracies
you know like everyone last week yeah
eddie broad wasn't my dog he loves
conspiracy
he on his last thing said that he shot a
cop
in westwood new jersey or something
watch the [ __ ] thing on hbo it's on
youtube it's got to be on youtube all
three of them on youtube
but he tells a story on there very
nonchalantly
about that he got to kill a
cop
paul peter something and he shot the guy
and he goes who gave you the other side
of the booger
right there there was a fed watching
that
and part of the [ __ ] witness
relocation thing is that you've never
shot a cop
or ever contracted a murderer on a cop
in their statement they read through the
statement sammy never
contacted that hit
do you follow them saying to you like
they figured out that sammy never told
them by this point
they had so many people coming in
telling their stories and they were
throwing them out because they were
going
you're a liar
sammy told us something different
but one day they figured out after eight
people came in
he was lying to us yeah
this [ __ ] but you know sammy was
genius because he turned himself in
first so they're going to believe his
story before anybody and he knew the
nuts and bolts he wasn't no henry hill
faker he knew the nuts and bolts of what
was going on so when he went in there
they bought his story hook on the sinker
they got so blind they didn't even care
what he told them they just wanted john
gotti yeah they got so blinded by
getting john gotti that they took
whatever oh you killed 24 people don't
worry about it
oh my god 24 was what he killed the one
year yeah you know what he was
responsible for the one [ __ ] year
jesus christ so they put it all together
and they because of that documentary on
hbo
gravano was already in jail for the
ecstasy with the [ __ ] uh neo-nazis in
phoenix they picked them up
and they put him under the [ __ ] jail
in denver
at that superman supermax but here's the
beauty of it yeah
the iceman
died mysteriously in his jail cell a
weak later yeah
you know people like conspiracies there
you go [ __ ] take that to the moon
yeah right take that to the [ __ ] moon
and back i love it i love it how you
feeling buddy i'm at the moon this
yellow thing is helping though how did
you know that would help no because it's
a calming effect it's a common of the
yellow you're from that generation
yeah like french poodles but you're also
talking to guys who've done acid like a
lot okay and you gotta have focus and
sometimes in 10 years that yellow won't
do dick for you no you're not throwing
that into my face you know what i'm
saying but now but now tonight you'll
need that yellow yeah like it's helping
into this yeah what's happening
turn lights off for the rest of the
podcast and just talk to each other with
a candle
like that i'm like look at these
puerto ricans would you like them
it doesn't sound fun i don't know what
porter you can sound
you just come up with stuff on the
outside
when we come up with stuff even though
without acid oh my god your little head
is shiny oh my god i just i'm not so i
can't stop sweating i can feel the heat
see this is this is the and i'm not like
last time monday this i was freaking out
at this point
this is now like i'm still a little
nervous we know that you beat you okay
he's like okay
it helps it helps with that oh my god
it's just burning straight through it
what do you have tomorrow my friend
nothing else nothing nothing now nothing
now
okay i'm about to
we're done that's it we can't keep doing
this to ourselves that's what we keep
saying but then next time monday we'll
be back here [ __ ] 18 drops coming
they'll have a new setup like i'll be
i'll be happy we lost that strip of acid
we've been we lost that for six months
a sheet of acid oh my god
that's the [ __ ] that goes all the way
back to london that acid
kid who gave me that it was a chip chick
charlie ho dude that's the [ __ ] that
pink floyd took when he put the band a
chip chip challenge that's the [ __ ]
that's that's the cousin to the acid
yeah take a piece of paper home with you
give it to the hotel manager
i come in tonight
we're talking about the ass and talking
about this
i look on the shelf the acid's been on
that shelf right there for the last six
months see people i don't steal it's
sticking
i thought he clipped it so we didn't
have to do it
see if i was smart enough i would have
done that and i wouldn't let him find it
i thought he clipped and sold on ebay
oh my god i should have
how you doing can you open it for me
i know you need help
honestly we even eat those that was the
beginning of lee's downfall oh my god
yeah he was a great kid
until cheaper
cheers she would choose people and those
cookies oh they're so kind they're so
kind cookies i don't think you know man
i don't know if they don't make those no
more do they oh they don't come up here
maybe so kind's still on they just don't
come i don't know chiva chews everywhere
though man and it is [ __ ] good
and i was [ __ ] having a hard time
with this too and i just
did anything with two yeah we don't do
that 180 milligrams nothing nothing
i got it we don't do nothing
chiba chews is still a great product i
miss him yeah i missed eating that one
it was delicious delicious it's like a
[ __ ] uh tootsie roll but 200
milligrams it's like it you know we need
five of those today
look at lee's getting sick already and
stuff you're right
i'm fine now but i'm not going to eat
that so yeah you're not going to eat it
no give me one like give me i will eat
but just give me [ __ ] yourself you made
me open it you're eating it i'm going to
eat it but this guy you don't want me to
puke on you no i don't want you to puke
on me [ __ ] you better not be
people got spare t-shirts here tonight
we got spare
yeah like you got spare t-shirts for me
[ __ ] don't [ __ ] yourself great
i'll use one of those size [ __ ]
medium to wipe my titty [ __ ] drive
put two strings around those pillows and
[ __ ]
like one of those guys from the 50s this
[ __ ] the circus is in town tonight you
have a little billboard and [ __ ]
[ __ ] it i'll take you to the car every
time i come here i gotta tell you this
the other day i was i turned on my tv
and and uh and i get this new [ __ ]
cable in nashville where you just i call
it stevie tv it's like from xfinity but
you just hold on to it and you say it
and i go out loud josie wells
boom outlaw josie wells
anytime i [ __ ] want it
boom for free all right listen to me
when he's talking to [ __ ] 10 bears
and he's talking about that's the most
okay
go [ __ ] yourself go [ __ ] yourself these
people today all right you kevin
costners and all these [ __ ] go [ __ ]
yourself you want to take acting schools
too much you're good for what they do
it's [ __ ] amazing
it's the people now make a big deal
about
and they never gave clance with any
credit no you watched that scene a holy
[ __ ]
when he's talking about ten bears and
about about their [ __ ] you know his
mark on that and we'll jerk beef every
spring [ __ ] big man
[ __ ] talk about let's i'm
listen i want to be an actor if it's on
i have it on for 10 or 15 to 20 minutes
again
josie wales comes on
it stays on till i gotta make a move
which is 20 minutes dirty right right
but the last three weeks the part's been
coming on
my all-time favorite with the kids
bleeding oh yeah
and he goes i'll give him the bucket
though give me
where's the bucket over there
give him a bucket he's starting to see
the devil touch the robe yellow yellow
yellow
[Music]
you ain't cheap at you i'm trying to
right that's what i'm doing oh that's
why you're getting sick yeah oh my god
drink the water quickly let's go come on
what let's go leigh we got a podcast ten
years he's still [ __ ] drugs eating
chocolate i was trying to eat him in
silence
no there's never no silence with you oh
there's always going to be a noise
there's always a grunt there's always
stop giving me all those [ __ ] drugs
then
oh yeah yeah
you're the only guy who complained about
that complaining at all
i'm telling you my daughter's my
daughter made that yellow is helping in
it it's helping a lot it's helping a lot
whenever i see that [ __ ] scene
i don't know
i always watch listen whenever
lately i've been catching the other
scene now
i go for a stretch like in three months
where every time i turn it on it's the
scene right when he sees
the young bucks and then he goes down
there yeah and he gives them the sign of
the whole thing that whole [ __ ] spiel
like i said that's deadly that's an
acting class that's it that's that and
the godfather is all you need to watch
if you don't get it after that then i
can't help you
i cannot help you
when uh brando is at the meeting
and he's talking about his son what
happened i'm not a superstitious man
yeah all that stuff something should
happen
listen all that stuff that's an acting
let's acting 101 that's as good as it
[ __ ] gets in my world it was until
this moment i knew it was barcelona the
whole time
oh my god that's so deadly
when you watch that you just get
shivering so hbo even after 80 years the
godfather still the oldest movie
they still talk [ __ ] about it
hbo is doing another thing about it now
it just released the other day i just
saw hbo i was watching hbo and they said
new announced hbo francis ford coppola
hbr teaming up again to do this
the unseen foot just a ton of [ __ ]
they're going to do again wow the
movie's that [ __ ] interesting i guess
huh man i you know i never knew when uh
when when um uh oh god i'm blanking out
because of those drugs um
when uh the get the cannolis okay that
he goes in and sits down and has a whole
spaghetti dinner all right it's a he's
like guys i'll be right back i'll be
right back he goes in all right and he
he sits down it's a whole huge plate of
pasta
all right all right it was bruno kirby's
guy and then and and one remember okay
and he's a he gets the cannolis and
everything and has a meatball and
[ __ ] all this [ __ ] and his guys are
waiting on him like it's some big
transaction he's having [ __ ] dinner
before dinner it's hysterical he's he
makes them all go there guys keep your
eyes open all right like i'm gonna go in
here and see these people he walks in
it's the back of the kitchen he takes
his jacket off he hangs it up and [ __ ]
there's a little table waiting for him
he sits there
it's a [ __ ] three-course meal
meanwhile they think the mafia is coming
they're out there with guns
blazing he comes out 20 minutes later
after a good meal man that was a that
was a hectic meeting
how you doing you're breathing heavy oh
yeah the cops are coming everything do
you think they're coming for you no
they're not i'm not there yet but
why aren't you there yet i don't know i
need another sugar cube no more sugar no
more sugarcoats usually not tonight you
do another sugar cube legally not too
much at the [ __ ] zoo naked
holding onto a tree and [ __ ]
that would be hilarious you got to take
a picture like that dude no one wants to
see me naked holding it
tree hanging down that'd be [ __ ] like
it was oh when i listen i went for years
without doing this [ __ ] i hooked up with
lee and since lee didn't know anything
about this i kept busting these balls
until someday somebody actually brought
one yeah to the show that's what
happened we talked about it on here
we talked about mushrooms or somebody
showed up at the show with chocolate
covered mushrooms yeah you know it's
always [ __ ] something at those shows
you know and i'm not gonna say no what
the [ __ ] i bring them back and me and
lee experiment and we try them out
i was just breaking his balls with the
acid all some people started showing up
with liquid acid
and people started saying
you know i i hadn't heard that acid
asset apparently is making a huge
comeback
because there for like like 10 15 years
as it wasn't real [ __ ] big
but people scared the name of it
yeah right it's got such a negative
[ __ ] thing when you get acid you're
like
it's so funny we do the same thing
yeah god damn we've been friends for 20
years now yeah when you get acid as a 13
or 14 year old you're like i'll never do
that [ __ ]
and all of a sudden you're the rolling
stone concert and you're really [ __ ]
you're like [ __ ] starting me up nick
what the [ __ ] has happened to my life
the two there was one particular there
was one night that was horrible like
like there's coke nights and there's
pill nights and there's alcohol nights
there was two ass oh yeah yellow is
moving now so that's not good yeah
that's not good that's good
it was good to them it was good it's
good up until until it starts sneaking
around all right all right
lesson one down okay good leave the
snake out for me all right lay this
thing oh jesus christ
slither around the table
lisa i had a it was my 17th birthday
party
all right it's my 17th birthday party
and we broke into my house
the one where i lived and yeah
it was a monday afternoon we walked in
there about two in the afternoon no heat
yeah no electricity february 19th
happy birthday is coming two in the
afternoon we got our jackets up in the
attic we're drinking [ __ ] beer we
could hear the mice running around
because the electricity was off and then
i was on
we started eating those micro dot hits
of acid man
we started popping them we probably ate
like three of them
we each gone
we walked in there and the sun was out
when we walked out of there it was dark
and people were tripping their balls off
and i was one of them
yeah you're in your [ __ ] own house
man no no no no no no at that time i
didn't live in my house oh yeah i broke
into my house i know i was living with
the benders
we went up there as a party but one
thing i remember we were i was tripping
so hard
i went
i went downstairs
he's going through changes ladies and
gentlemen
i went downstairs to pete oh my goodness
and louis hernandez
was puking
and i pulled him back
was the only dominican kid in the
neighborhood but he had an afro so they
called him louis [ __ ]
and he would have to say a thousand
times listen i'm dominican they didn't
give a [ __ ] in 1970. not very good
yeah
[ __ ] crazy how racist it really was
that these people do nothing today they
don't know what they went through louis
was dominican they called him louis
[ __ ]
unbelievable to his face oh man if he
still pops up in north bergen they'll go
oh look what it looked like
i don't think i've ever heard about
louise
in the seventh grade we were [ __ ]
all in seven
seventh grade in basketball and awesome
god just started dropping things on us
he dropped louie hernandez on honest
i got left back and i practiced all
summer so i got good we had david ruiz
and we just had this great [ __ ] team
i forget who oh we had dominic speciale
and chucky mcbreen
that's how deep we were you know
uh uh acid and and then in your old
house when you're
broken
was puking in the toilet and i basically
pulled him by the afro i said louie i'm
sorry i put my dick in the corner like
this
and i put his head back in and i go go
ahead
but i left there that night
and it was just chunk and it was the
first birthday without my mom i was
cracked
i was cracked and i walked into that
bender house
and they're like hey you want dinner and
stuff and they don't know that i'm on
fire
i'm burning on acid they're talking to
me and i see wigs on fire oh i see
everything that they're not seeing i go
right into that bedroom above the subway
it's seven o'clock at night i [ __ ] go
into that bedroom i light myself in
there lock myself in there i'm like i'm
not even leaving this room yeah right
and the [ __ ] phone starts right
those days people that have phones in
their rooms or cell phones you had to
actually leave your room and come
downstairs
and louis uh lisa had here's the beauty
they had a mirror
right in front of the phone and i went
and i'm like hello and i started
and they're like uh you're coming out
tonight at your birthday i'm like yeah
i'll be out of the one
i looked at the mirror
and all of a sudden my face started to
melt in the mirror and [ __ ]
and i'm like hold on i gotta call you
but dawg i'll never forget i started
tripping right there i couldn't look at
anything that's when you're like [ __ ]
i'm going to my room yeah and you just
go in your room you don't even look at
nothing lee because everything you look
at starts shifting that's where i am
right now and it's just a little bit
that's what i was saying on monday it's
just because i can't even close my eyes
because
you close your eyes no because then you
call the colors start moving to it
doesn't
there's like
there's like a 20-minute period where
i'm [ __ ] oh i'm saying i'm in it right
now so it's just dog i'm starting to see
little dragons i just saw a little
[ __ ] uh thing behind your head though
there was little bats the other night
there was a little there was little mop
like a little thing what do you call
those things
like a little tiny one
and it would
it was everywhere he was the other night
like it flew in though the lee was
tripping yeah for like a half hour i
watched this more just tormently to
death i didn't even know it was there
remember you said i just saw him back
wasn't no [ __ ] bad it was literally
what's up
oh my god it was a month oh it's christ
okay i know all right
and um
back in houston
all right and uh
this was this was like late 90s
uh we did acid and mitch hedberg
all right was over at the house and and
it was like me and john wessling and and
uh
one other person and dude we did acid
and
[ __ ] greatest time in my life
but one guy was nervous that a [ __ ]
dragon was going to kill him all right
and you had to tell him no there's no
sense of dragons
they're not even real they're not even
real they say that dragons are not real
no no but pterodactyls they're real no
they're not they were real they were god
god
all right we keep looking keep on
looking like listen no [ __ ] league
because we can't lose lead though
if there's i'm gone
[ __ ] dragons he just took church
communion over here for the first time
how are you feeling my tour manager ben
ben are you loosening up a little bit
yeah loosens you up yeah right that's it
i'm smoking a cigarette drinking water
getting a feeling about it i'm sure ben
and i got the same dose don't wonder
don't wander nowhere stay where you are
okay yeah all right he's a wonderful
they always are the first time they
don't know [ __ ] it find a couch let life
come to you [ __ ]
yeah yeah it's like when willy wonka
took him to the chocolate factory he
didn't take him on as it they got on the
[ __ ] boat and [ __ ] just hit it oh
i cannot blow that oh yeah
oh listen bro that 170 north is close by
you get lost on that it's all over don't
you they won't fire up those sherman
whales [ __ ]
what is it about l.a that causes people
to run from the cops
oh my gosh do you see that black guy
today it's every day here it's amazing
today or how about this stupid [ __ ]
white guy he
there was a stupid white guy in a white
minivan today they drove up on two cops
that he had a gun in the car and then
took him on a [ __ ] eight mile round
the world slow chase like he's got oj in
there all right and then gets out and
just and at one point a guy with a
camera yeah i saw that walks up to him
he's like hey why are you where you
running from the cops and the guy's got
the camera the guy supposedly says he's
got a gun and you're [ __ ] over there
with a camera you dumb [ __ ] and where
were the cops if a
[ __ ] fat ass with a beta cam can get
right there by the guy why couldn't a
cop go hey you want to get the [ __ ] out
the car all right please can we just
stop this i saw that too when i someone
the cameraman literally he must have
been following where you're going on a
cigarette sack don't throw them over
because they'll invictus the helicopter
don't think it's leaked oh yeah they
will yeah i can blame for everything in
this and this in this city for
everything north hollywood i'm blamed
for big up we'll
the [ __ ] people want to run from the
cops oh yeah
like i just i never saw that and
everyone's faces are moving now um
i never saw that anywhere else in my
whole life running from the cops
you never ran from the cops [ __ ] no
really
not even as a kid i haven't run from
anything let's say you are
i hate running i have short legs
it's not fair dude i can't even walk
next to people
you took it you took it from a [ __ ]
the greatest of all time i don't run
from anything
i got short legs i'm a dumpy jew okay me
too i got dough no but you never got
chase as a kid with some spray painting
[ __ ] no lighting the fire at the park
and somebody go hey you little bastards
and you run away nothing no i was like i
guess i might my town was super white as
it is but
i was like the whitest of the whites
nobody you hung out with one of the
light of fire or [ __ ] oh yeah
like a cat on fire and nothing but these
kids weren't normal
no we didn't say cats on fire we would
set like little fires in our yards or in
the
driveways
what about the the bullfrogs with the
firecrackers no we didn't do that
oh man okay well y'all ain't from the
south because let me tell you what you
get some of them straight from [ __ ]
tijuana m80s all right and put strap a
[ __ ] bullfrog on that [ __ ] oh
my god boom
[ __ ] get out the way are you kidding me
those things went off that was like a
quarter stick of dynamite he says oh my
god oh my god lady you have to do shows
for peter's frog just went everywhere
just everywhere
but they're not endangered come on we're
spreading the love all right we're
feeding the other animals bro you never
know not in today's world
they might show up with something else
they might show up with something [ __ ]
you already know [ __ ] three frogs you
killed i hate frogs dog
when i was i'm a new york city kid and
i'm going out of miami and the fur like
the first frogs in there are [ __ ] big
bro in miami
i couldn't sleep at night when i was a
kid i guess they they're loud as [ __ ]
no no no listen i don't want them around
me i don't want to eat them you're not
going to eat frogs not never
not even close not even by mistake
not even do i want to look at that thing
when you tell me you got this guy at the
table i excuse myself
i gotta go
right can we just say that i mean i've
been saying it for 20 years nobody
listens i i'm a guy you never had it in
my house it was always blue cheese it
might that's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
always blue cheese in my house [ __ ] out
of respect for buffalo hello
what oh my god good football we are
[ __ ] synchronizing oh my god
[ __ ] it little shout out to buffalo
[ __ ] [ __ ] dubs and our anchor bar hey
don't leave going through changes run
upon some black sabbath nope no i do not
want to pull out but let's put on black
sabbath
that's okay what i'm can we put on by
but to really take it to the next level
oh man great acid music yeah um
no no uh a [ __ ] uh led zeppelin
you need
oh
no no you're scared
you're scared all i got you and dean
delray and it's all over don't end up in
the hospital room
don't wander this ain't a good neighbor
the one then no no no no on that train
they'll take you downtown it's all over
one minute you're in a protest next
minute you're sucking a drummer on your
head
saying free the [ __ ] villanovas
what's up lee i'm doing good i'm just it
just hit it just hits me strong i'm
enjoying it
i'm just enjoying listening to you guys
talk
okay i'll tell you what when you were
smoking before i could smell it oh yeah
i thought something was burning i'm like
something's on [ __ ] fire building i'm
like this [ __ ] seems like
they're smoking [ __ ] i don't like the
music with it it gets my heartbeat my
heart's going a mile a minute right now
then you need you need some you you need
some red zepplin right now because let
that let you go a little high and then
it'll slow it down you know and then a
little higher then a little low no but
they do the
the base and then it [ __ ] gets your
heart going it gets me that's when them
drums kick in when that [ __ ] when the
horse tranquilizes [ __ ] drums hit
that's when the shit's over jack you got
to be ready you got to be on the train
or you're left to the station that's all
i'm saying right
you need food
this is training week this like shark
week in the podcast business
this is like shark week in the podcast
business for us
we got to go into [ __ ] and that's it
every week is this week it sounds like
we take an easy week
this week but that's why people love the
church because it's it's the real [ __ ]
everybody you never know what you're
gonna get this week on the church we're
doing kale shakes and yeah that's never
gonna [ __ ] happen no no let's go [ __ ]
yourself it's all right now it's okay
all right now we have three kinds of
acid all right let's see what
yeah and listen people are going to
start selling it from all over the world
now without about a month we're going to
have
so much acid stock
it's all over you have isis acid dude
okay they're going to come back
you got to take it you got gotta point
towards mecca while you're driving
they're not gonna pull us under the jet
we don't know nothing oh my god they're
gonna flavor your falafel all right
they're gonna give you that [ __ ]
straight from the [ __ ] i don't give
you [ __ ]
no hammer on or whatever that is that
[ __ ] uh where's your people from over
there in in uh israel come on
from russia
oh you're a dirty russian yeah i'm a
dirty russian oh christ thank god you're
a jew i wouldn't even stand near you oh
my god i ain't never gambling with you
lee i love you but if you're a russian i
can't gamble it didn't work out for
[ __ ] denzel it ain't gonna work out
for me you know what i'm saying
we went to see john week two i haven't
seen it yet it comes out this week right
i don't know i think it comes out so i'm
happy because
the guy who trains him is in it he put
him in there as a cab driver he give him
a chance so i'm happy for him dude how
about how strong was uh uh
what was that place we used to go have
breakfast on sunset
pads not pads
the place the diner
that we go on on uh down the strip by
the roxie yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and keanu just all the time
just [ __ ] just roll right in
cool like a [ __ ] dukes dukes and
he was always cool
cut french fries nice cheese omelette
stop dabbing coca-cola if you want to be
fat that's where you go to breakfast
dukes i'd eat the [ __ ] and i tell
them forget those home fries give me all
the regular fries at seven in the
morning you could switch up to regular
fries lee who's better than you that's
[ __ ] awesome i do that at denny's
wait in the morning at seven in the
morning i don't really go i mean
if i get the uh the one of the
sandwiches yeah i [ __ ] i don't like
hash browns
oh god damn
lee i'm a southerner you're spitting in
my face yeah but don't like hashbrowns
got aids yeah that's okay denny's one's
got aids all right but you come down and
i'll put you on some hash browns oh i'm
sure that i'll i'll bring you to jesus
that's how i'll take his past jew the
right sour cream and he'll put [ __ ]
cheddar cheese oh stop that [ __ ]
if i'm about to get blamed for it [ __ ]
your [ __ ] sweet ass that came out of
jail i don't blame nobody all right all
right but you're the one who first said
something so eventually it's gonna come
to me and you're gonna [ __ ] hit me
like you did in [ __ ] el paso with
your bed shot on payback all right that
was your birthday that was your birthday
yeah it was your birthday we we were in
el paso working we had the red devil
with us giving [ __ ] to mencia okay and
we [ __ ] that was 99 99 and we [ __ ]
went and saw payback
and and because me and joey both wanted
to [ __ ] lucy lou and she's throwing
sidekicks and had a little asian [ __ ]
just looking at you just winking
just winking
all right and then and you they got
quiet
and joe did
you [ __ ] let out a fart
that was
tremendous as a man to a man i gotta
tell you and i've had phenomenal fights
ben's been a witness
ricocheted off the chair oh in between
the two lines the reverberating
[Music]
and right before mel gibson was about to
spit his line it went
and everybody everybody [ __ ] heard it
like it was just embarrassing like
everybody heard it in the movie theater
i was
why did you do this and everybody's
[ __ ] looking at me and i'm like
goddamit coco jesus i didn't know it was
99 now oh my god
hey we all are now we're getting really
[ __ ] old yeah
how's that yellow treat
it's on the snake right now so it's okay
it's last night
ah
as soon as it starts moving last 20
minutes late i've been doing this and
you're going oh my god oh my god
listen to me
i could torture you to death on acid
if you think i could torture you in
regular life
what i could do on acid i'll have you
call 9-1-1
you'll be like that dude chris heather
when the cop showed up
and gave his own risk
that's what would do
you understand me i could take them away
i could take a [ __ ] real life
and torment oh that's okay
what do you mean that you could do
that's what you're doing to me
it's gonna be all right ladies on a
daily basis
dragon fire did you hear that
oh
hilarious oh my god lisa you're so
[ __ ] funny i don't try to be i know
that's what makes you great
if you tried you wouldn't be nearly as
funny
holy [ __ ]
oh my god before lee
i'm surprised we're not pulling your
little poor head
i can't throw a snake at somebody on
there
look at the first one that's the first
smaller assets
like it's [ __ ] fight club first thing
about half the club is you don't do
snakes
no snakes no [ __ ] lizards
pterodactyls ladies and gentlemen this
is it
this is the thing that
this is what you did when you were 16
you dropped the hit of mescaline you
went to somebody's garage i went to the
movies you know and this is what this is
doing to the movies this is it for four
or five hours it's a constant and have a
blessing fest
torture this poor kid they taught you me
did your mother call my mother's dead
why would she you know
it never ends it never ends
you know that's what you do i mean dog
like i said i'm the master of tormenting
your voice oh my god all right i wanted
to tell you this one time this is how
much i got it before you got it
i'm
i survived the [ __ ] 2017. oh my god
come on anytime in town if i you got me
in a thousand seconds no ways
dude
this this [ __ ] was so funny
coco would drink all the juice
and then we'd come out and go
who [ __ ] drank all the juice where
the [ __ ] is the juice and i'm like god
damn coco i just made some juice i
thought oh [ __ ] i got one my can i make
that juice up stir it up if i i swear to
god be watching a movie hey rob you want
something from the kitchen and get a
glass of water he drank the other chunk
of juice
okay you are a vitamin c you were orange
you were trump before trump you're
snorting coke yeah right you gotta get
it [ __ ] lifeline you gotta get it
when you get it
oh my god and then you're going mommy
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] who drank
the artist
that's this guy who drank the iron i was
blaming on everybody but me
looking poorly it's good you're good
you're solid i'm good there's no purple
walls we'll just shut the podcast down
in 10 minutes
we'll put music on [ __ ] put the
purple lights on for you the whole thing
yeah right we'll play the air guitar
play some cream white room we'll play
some [ __ ] we'll smoke some cigars and
[ __ ]
you know how we do it lee yeah nice and
easy for you if you're gonna ask it
go cream what
the the band cream leave him alone
please don't no no no he don't know he
don't want the music all right you put
music on he'll jump off the block and
then we gotta talk to that four hours
no no [ __ ] you gotta talk to the cops
[ __ ] hey i'll get you out of
here as fast as i did like that at
dublin's when you ate that coke rock in
the [ __ ] fridge
there won't be no footage on google maps
nobody
because i was thinking about that you
can't if they're really looking for you
they found yeah yeah yeah yeah they got
you done if there's a murder on
1482 smith street at 10 o'clock
all they got to do is get that google
map zoop it turn it back 10 minutes
let's see who walked in the [ __ ] out of
there it's crazy dude it probably costs
a lot of money to [ __ ] do right off
the bat but i don't
i can't say they don't already have that
no they haven't you know that they've
had it what do you mean if we thought
about it they already have yeah they're
already they're already on to the next
[ __ ] level and they don't need google
earth they have street light cameras and
yeah right cameras and all the
businesses they don't need google earth
we're doing it for them the camera
phones yeah your camera yeah you're the
head of the nsa before i i don't i don't
even do it but the head of the nsa
before said we should all be putting
tape over the cameras or relax oh yeah
they watch
[ __ ] it i'll go over there and dance in
front of them and just have the camera
on for nothing they can
tea bagging
[ __ ] yeah like i don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you no you don't want to have that
camera you got to tape that [ __ ] i don't
know that's why listen they don't want
to listen you have to they know
everything right at this point they got
everything everything they've pushed on
you is consumed for you to give them a
credit card yeah right
you could put any credit cards any slot
now within
30 seconds your whole credit history
comes it was creepy
i had a i had an issue wizard thing that
pipe oh
i had an issue where a credit card i had
to change the had the numbers changed
and i went to my uh gym to switch the
numbers like oh no the bank we already
they already contacted us and switched
the numbers
for the automatic payment i like
[ __ ]
like it's it's i guess it's okay but
it's [ __ ] weird
it's like the bank is working against
you
and everything's supposed to be working
for you is that what you mean
but it was just weird that like they
were giving my information to the gym
and then and then it was
it's weird every time i get a card from
bank of america it somehow magically
gets stolen
every time like i don't even get it i
don't even open it i just heard
bank of america
you just heard what happened no she's
what i'm saying to you while you're
watching parks and rec
yeah oh [ __ ] bank of america just got in
trouble for what they get in trouble for
[ __ ] no as well as fargo was
have you opened all these accounts and
they charge you and you didn't even have
these accounts and people weren't
[ __ ] and they weren't even [ __ ]
going through
the uh
shady [ __ ] man and and they just got
busted on but you know what i mean i'm
[ __ ] i'm tired of hearing people but
if we if we can't you know will shoot a
black guy who stole a [ __ ] ham
sandwich okay but we didn't do anything
to those [ __ ] sucking bankers all right
and now trump's got them all in their
cabinet those [ __ ] should be in
jail they're [ __ ] bigger thieves than
any of us they're bigger thieves than
anybody
and they just [ __ ] stole and we just
let them
[ __ ] all right and they call us
the [ __ ] criminals and outlaws we
smoke reefer you know what i didn't do
take your grandma's [ __ ] yum yum
money okay i didn't do that all right
i didn't [ __ ] i didn't uh i didn't
make sure that you're [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
where you going
the whole wall behind you is moving now
so it's
i love it lee lee you need to take a hit
sure i know you did
no you think about it all your
information is gone
it's gone it's all gone it's all gone
it's all gone man it's all gone and it's
sad to think i don't mean to
and to you know put anybody in a bad
mood but it's the reality yeah once you
type once you bought those pair of shoes
or you got those [ __ ] that plane
ticket online and you used your amex
that's it yeah they got everything when
when you call the phone come when you
call the airline already
their security system's so high-tech
that while you're talking to them with
your phone number and stuff everything
comes up right
everything comes up they already know
what card you're going to use which is
so pissed it pisses me off when they
like they make you go through the whole
system and they already know who you are
yeah they already know i don't know what
the whole [ __ ]
sorry
no man we're fascinated
i'm with you i'm over here too [ __ ]
burning up i just know how to cover it
up lisa
you know
i'm not seeing [ __ ] ghosts or you
know spirits and [ __ ] but take over here
totally come on i'm not as [ __ ] i
don't know what wednesday for some
reason whenever i do this i can't take a
deep breath
i'm off this week bro yeah and i always
seem to forget that like i always
when i go to nashville when i go to
these cities
you know when you work you work man yeah
i'm a grown [ __ ] man i get tired
those [ __ ] early morning flights kill
me
you know so when i'm [ __ ] off
i'm off
right you know yeah i write jokes and i
send my emails i take care of my
business but
nice i'm off i'm not in training camp
i'm not thinking of shooting anything or
tape or anything that's the most distant
thing from my [ __ ] mind i'm off i'm
just doing a podcast on a wednesday
night with two [ __ ] savages that's it
that's it let me give some shout outs
before i forget real quick
to some bad [ __ ]
hold on one second
i'm not gonna [ __ ] that guy
bam there you go hello i ain't [ __ ] up
jennica jones brandi lynn i'll see you
in minneapolis in two weeks
trapper welton gravity king
manny moreno
jay unitos ookie spooky our girl i love
ryan scott
and fernando zarilla
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
there you go
i'm not sitting there well hey uh
you know i just want to give him some
shout outs these are the people i love
these guys man
my buddy enforcer uh he's paul marsh
down in little rock [ __ ] is a member
of the church okay he's deep in love all
right wants to give you moonshine and
watch you [ __ ] get all [ __ ] up on
that okay uh look at paul's [ __ ]
great people um uh also i heard today
from ricky cruz down in florida his
boy's out of the hospital
his boy had a uh had a sinus infection
and uh and and they took it to the er
the doctor said oh it's a virus and the
sinus infection got so bad that there
was an abscess in the little boy's
sinuses all right this little boy is
seven years old god bless all right and
so the little boy had he was in icu for
like nine days had to have surgery okay
and and and he does all this and he and
he and i'm talking to him and i'm like
what mikey where can i get you where are
you are you okay you know i said
everything for kids okay and and he goes
uncle ralphie you uh maybe like legos or
something i sent that kid every kind of
lego they had i sent him everything the
kid goes to that all he wants is a lego
god damn it you got heart kid you almost
died all right because i've been there
for nine days nine days dude the abscess
got so close
you know the little bones in there
they're so close to the brain and and
this these dumb [ __ ] er doctors who
don't give it two shits all right you
know to look you know take five minutes
look at a kid all right what's the color
of the snot okay you know what hey he's
seven
let's give him antibiotics anyway just
to make sure he's okay all right it's
[ __ ] miami trust me he'll need extra
antibiotics for something all right you
know he's only seven but he'll still
need it okay
and it's like and that little boy
ricky and i were working together we
were in west palm and uh and he left
every day and every night and it was
like his wife was like i took it to the
er
he had a fever and spikes and oh my gosh
oh my god that's terrible it's horrible
it's horrible
but god bless him
okay yeah he's okay now thank god i know
thank god
ricky ricky's a brother you know ricky's
ricky's family from the old school old
school family 1440. i still remember
beating joe chadwick and ricky was mad
ricky was like you can't do that [ __ ]
him
he pays his 300 to host
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you
joe chadwick
he wanted me to mc and i told him send
me the plane ticket yeah send me cash
and i just said [ __ ] it i broke down in
vegas i'm not coming
and me and ricky split the dough
what the [ __ ] is with the planes oh god
they're coming for the lake because he's
not asking ah jesus christ they're
probably looking at all them
pterodactyls flying around outside and
wondering what the hell is going on the
jurassic park pterodactyls pop out here
what's going on
what's happening lee
sounds like the pterodactyl's coming
home
should we close the door
no [ __ ] it i don't know
unless you want to close the door no huh
oh my god it's so funny
[Music]
his eyes
look weird now oh yeah oh yeah both of
y'all are finding the right spot aren't
you i'm good
yeah yeah
burning calories like a [ __ ] but
i'm good yeah right
i guess it's fun
if i didn't have court drama i'd take
somebody so
save me some send me some of the listen
let me tell you something it's not like
i don't think they're making this stuff
or
first off my tolerance is off the chains
yeah what the [ __ ] yeah right my
tolerance is off the [ __ ] chains at
all levels yeah
but you know he's sitting there like he
had a cup of coffee he's like oh ralphie
that is interesting
no
trust me this little kick to this little
kick in this mule right now
i'm not seeing devils or [ __ ]
snakes yeah i just felt somebody tickle
my arm though
yeah every once in a while you just
gotta break out of the ordinary i love
doing
different types of podcasts man i really
do i love experimenting in here
there's nights we eat mushrooms there's
nights we just [ __ ] smoked mushrooms
we smoked mushrooms yeah smoked
mushrooms well now yeah
like an animal oh we did
yeah right [ __ ] it it'll burn some ways
we'll be all right
it's kind of good to [ __ ] just get
[ __ ] up from time to time yeah right i
think if i ate the mushrooms i'd be
having diarrhea
like i said this [ __ ] dog i go home i i
force myself to eat something yeah and
that's that kills it yeah that kills it
on the drive home you know listen
i'm old school if i see something i i
just walk home
yeah old school i just walk home with
uber you know i couldn't believe it i
just drove home went home
i sat there for 15 minutes i watched tv
you know what
let me see i think she went to rounds
i got some salami and a piece of
american cheese on a piece of wonder
bread like a doctor 10 minutes later i
was napping noodle
that's [ __ ] it was [ __ ] napping he
told me he stayed up on that yeah
yeah all the time oh my god but then the
one time i did it with ahri when went to
see what that kid went to see the pink
floyd same thing happened that night
i never sleep on it we took the answer
at 6 30
by 8 o'clock we were kind of burning by
nine we walked into that what's the
famous restaurant downtown philipps
yeah yeah we walked into philipps
tripping our balls off
we ordered food the food came then we
looked at each other
like who's going to eat this [ __ ]
like who's going to eat this [ __ ] who
would eat this who ordered this [ __ ] how
did we get in here give us a tap we're
out of here because you want boxes [ __ ]
no
we got on the train we went to the house
and we ended up watching something
stupid on tv oh the bounty hunter chick
with the [ __ ] with mickey rourke in
there
i don't know yeah yeah yeah bounty
whatever the [ __ ] with mickey rourke and
the black dude
dwindle lingo whatever his name is he
was the black dude that uh
what's the big movie we were good
delrin del lindo
not pulp fiction what the [ __ ] was he in
the one with uh travolta
and [ __ ] get shorty
yeah
del rey lindo
yeah something like that i like that guy
yeah he was great and that gets shorty
yeah
i don't even know what the [ __ ] we're
talking about no no no but you get
mesmerized by which black guy it is like
this is like like i don't know which one
like yeah yeah that's [ __ ] awesome i
don't know how you doing
i'm doing good i'm
tripping my balls off but
i love it what are you seeing
it's just a lot of mixing it's a lot
like twirly mixing
like like swirling like this
or like that
another first one like this yeah the
wheels went like starry night like
starry night ones yeah okay yeah because
this one that's badasses
okay this one's the good ass is it
it's both it's both
i don't know and like even in my pee
the last time
like i have a picture on my phone of one
time i took acid and i shaved my my head
and my beard and i thought the hair
looked so magical and i took a picture
of it i have it on my phone it looks
stupid
look it just looks like a [ __ ]
it looks like a sink whatever
whatever worked for you that night
don't shave anything okay i'm doing you
a silence yeah it was weird that it felt
weird wait till four in the morning in
the middle of the tonight when you have
a good time shave an eyebrow taking
chance no
just shaving like bro
take a chance you are a 12 year old
[Applause]
every weekend is a different color it's
sticky on the rooster you know what i'm
saying
a little red yeah you got it high
oh my god right here
i used to do that [ __ ] to people all the
time when i was growing up putting air
on you when you were sleeping
oh and then you take a shower in the
head would fall off
oh man oh my god
they used to have some wicked [ __ ] they
don't do it no more people lost them
remember lemon up
remember that shampoo that you put in
your hand it was lemons and your hair
got lined up it wasn't like lighting up
yeah right yeah limit up lighting up
we're lighting up levels
there was a shampoo in the 70s yeah it
was [ __ ] huge everybody once
june came you got that shampoo and you
put it in your hair and you had got all
the light and [ __ ] and you got sexy for
the summer yeah but by some tummy like a
dirty horn
that was the first invasion of the dirty
[ __ ] it was the lemonade yeah from
there it all went downhill oh god
yeah
i
i gotta tell you
what is the [ __ ] deal all right what
are you do you gonna tell stories about
how
loud
when you go to gavin's
the producer's apartment and
and clog up a shower
[Music]
what
with his toe and it was such a good turn
it wouldn't go down it had a heart
that's exactly what happened
and then he said the water started
coming right up on you all right
shut the [ __ ] up you know i remember
these things and so you washed your feet
in the clean because it was disgusting
you're like i'm catholic i can't do this
and you got out of here
and you're like there you go
and then you came over to my place just
in your [ __ ] in your little towel
gavin's towel i don't think i was gonna
get that towel back i think that became
my towel all right and then you finish
your shower
at least stop [ __ ] with the wiring
and [ __ ]
the microphone so you're gonna
electrocute yourself then we're gonna
have other problems
you okay kill i'm okay
all right
how about this one
come and go go go go
have you ever told him how you how you
[ __ ] up jay moore
with the [ __ ] magazines we told him
two weeks ago oh yeah you did
oh okay all right all right
i got more i got more
all right all right
how about how about that tag watch from
gavin i love you
i know you did
i know you didn't clip it i know you
didn't clip it but
you and me were the only ones who knew
you didn't clip it
all right i think he's like
he was he was [ __ ] going around
i'm gonna be as honest i can't yeah i
didn't give a [ __ ]
at that point in my life right do you
remember he came up to the store yeah he
tried to get tough on me with keith yeah
with little i looked at him like are you
[ __ ] crazy
what
listen i made some mistakes but what
really happened was
that a certain girl came up he hooked up
with her right and
he fell in love with her she told her he
was gonna move up here you remember that
story but six months before that they
hooked up skype
and they would whack off on the phone
and talk dirty to each other and dildos
and [ __ ] you know that was 1998 yeah
skype wasn't 10 cents a [ __ ] minute
then you know what i'm saying
so he started getting these bills and
going oh the bills are disappearing
you know who's putting these high
[ __ ] bills on my thing he was on that
whacking off he couldn't come to the
conclusion
then the watch disappeared there was
like three or four things the watch
disappeared like five and he came to my
house one morning
i was living with terry i was sleeping
at paris and he knocked on my goal
morning that morning i looked i'm like
oh
dogs
don't have a knock on my [ __ ] door
again
you want to see me you call and we'll
meet you later goodbye that was it yeah
and that what time was about to watch
yeah the watch was stolen he left it on
top of that but then he found it
right he couldn't make face
tell anybody and somebody saw it on his
wrist and said isn't that the watch he
stole yeah he goes no
uh
no
bought a fake one
yeah
so wait a second you had a real watch
it got stolen
and you went and bought a fake one the
exact kind of exact kind
you know the odds of that and we're not
talking [ __ ]
listen man i was no saint
no but you weren't dead but i wasn't the
devil either and you know what at that
point in my life
i was playing that role
for 20 [ __ ] years yeah
so i already knew i grew up in north
bergen where those guys would go
uh
you know [ __ ] ralphie
he stayed here to eight in the morning
snorting coke really you didn't help him
he didn't help him oh yeah i did a few
lines you know i mean what the [ __ ] i
drank a few beers no so it was all
ralphie yeah right when i was growing up
that was every morning when they walked
into hashways and one of the biggest
speakers in the city they go
[ __ ] coco kept us out those sex in
the morning really right you weren't it
was your car
yeah you could have threw me out of the
[ __ ] car three hours earlier but you
didn't exactly
it's just uh
i to i want to let another candle for
mama hash ways uh rice pudding god damn
that was delicious she's still alive
what a shame you know billy herrenda
moved to town
we talked from time to time
that's why nobody goes home no more yeah
right because there's nowhere to go
there's another good i mean you can go
to chance dragging in and still get a
strong egg roll
okay oh no no those places are still but
our base yeah right the one down the
corner where everybody went in and got a
roast beef sandwich and you knew mrs
hatcher you could put it on the arm for
credit right and you went behind the
counter and put your own salt mayonnaise
yeah make it make it nice pickles you
know
no no no no no no that was that and
that's what happened i spoke to another
friend of mine that called
in regard to something else about a
month ago and i go you come home a lot
and he goes
he goes after hash ways closed
i moved down here and i never came back
again yeah
wasn't that important
hash ways was so [ __ ] good dude you
could just get your [ __ ] uh whatever
was it chocolate sodas you used to give
me was it egg cream or something no the
yolks the uh
chocolate milk what chocolate milk is
better than you who i think
i had to get the full chocolate manure
you want chocolate milk when you want a
[ __ ] you who
you want a [ __ ] you who
i was good
7-eleven got you this nice i stopped
here and i go in and get you and i'm
good for the night
you think of you who you're good
it's amazing what are you who would do
to you was 16 ounce you
[ __ ] knew i i did i did the
everything that was before one of the
hash ways had the lump okay but mama
still came in and great rice pudding and
then that was my first time at hashways
this is how cool this place was six
months later eight months later
i
am going through and going [ __ ] it i
don't know any place i'm going to go
into the city i don't know any place i
want to park over there i'm going to
[ __ ] jfk boulevard [ __ ] yep and i'll get
off right right before i go into the
tunnel i'll go with jfk and then boom
pull right into hash ways
they i'm there i got to say hello i got
to tell them to tell coco they said
hello and then mama hashway not only did
i get my rose beef sandwich she made me
an extra one and then i she goes i heard
you love my rice pudding so here take a
bigger thing and she gave me extra rice
pudding and one of those cinnamon what
the [ __ ] what's the chips that they had
there that way
yeah wise chips
with that with the owl right yeah that's
the ones that's the [ __ ] ones it's
funny one day we were having a
conversation years ago and you were
talking about that pizza paul in your
neighborhood right yeah that is the best
pizza in the world to you
like to you like when you go home
no matter what anybody says no you gotta
go to johnny's on fifth street you still
go there and it still tastes as good as
it did when you were a [ __ ] kid
absolutely that was hash ways only with
yelling and screaming and uh people
giving gossip and you know
man how about that heart attack on a
roll in the morning that morning
sandwich that she'd make us
oh my god you picked up two of those
i mean
i started eating there you got a figure
in 1975
dark rafi i went up there i was a
downtown kid and i went up there
the world on the street was if you want
to get better in basketball you got to
go up there and play the rough games in
the daytime
and one day there's ken fuvio pagliario
he was the catcher on the baseball team
by mistake slammed me
and he goes man i'm sorry you know
so he got me a roast beef on rye
with swiss cheese thin shaved lettuce
let me tell you something when i bit
into that it was all over i never tasted
anything like that in my life
i went there every day after that too
it [ __ ] caught it yeah
till the end we did the documentary yeah
absolutely that's i didn't we didn't go
in that time we went in there at two
o'clock and the roast beef wasn't ready
i knew the m was in there yeah right
what what are you talking about what are
you talking about the roast used to be
done at 10 in the morning earlier
earlier you're eating the roast beef so
it's like when they first passed that
first bounce check you know the first
time they hit you with a bounce check
and they're like oh my wife didn't
deposit the fans
that first bound check
means to boogie with noogie it's only
going to get worse after here don't make
me give you references you're going to
say
that first basketball means run even if
they give you even they'll cash it right
away they make themselves look solid
what's going on i don't know don't
wonder don't wonder don't wonder don't
wander i'm gonna watch you like oh
let him want to [ __ ] it he's got a coat
on he'll be fine he just goes downstairs
who hasn't you know who has it this is a
very interesting night of podcasting i
have no idea what happened what it was
said i mean i think we had fun man i
know i left my balls up
and and at least i hadn't got to scare
him with the snake
that was tremendous you gotta say that
for the [ __ ] highlight reel all right
dude the only way i'll forgive you
ralphie is if i got a ten thousand
dollar stake at the at harrah's with the
blackjack table
not ten thousand i'll get you
i'll come on i'll we'll sit there
i'll give you and i don't know i gotta
start you're jewish relax
look man
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna let you
knock down
the table and not [ __ ] play with me i
mean here i'll give you money i'll keep
you there no no i'm not asking from you
oh my god oh my god
the snake the snake
focus on the yellow yeah find the yellow
so funny when you went out there it was
out there with the car
don't look now now you can't [ __ ]
look see what i'm saying
now i don't need you to look i could
stick my hand over when you went out
that casually i want you to cash out of
the left eye to
gotta watch that [ __ ] i'm watching them
you know that's a dea weight line here
god damn it
no
okay just so everyone else knows this
isn't for anyone who is listening to the
podcast this is just for him he's just
putting that in my head he's going to
call me in three hours
this is the da's outside
don't answer the door that's so funny
listen when they cancel he's ready to
sniff somebody's [ __ ] at this point
bobby slid oh my god torment him right
now i think about him every day for
pleasure and i go no i can't do this no
you can't call him one thing i'll listen
i can't take it
i've been clean for nine years it's
[ __ ]
i hooked up with a colombian he's
armenian too
he's like i love me an armenian this
guy's got the goods and he'll buy right
into it like what do you mean goods like
what do you mean what type of guts
i'm talking about in new york city 19
[ __ ] 73.
he is numb the flake your nose enough
like it's yellow chinese people look at
this yeah that's what i'm saying
come on really how much you're grabbing
just kidding with an outrageous price
give me 22.50 it was like
bam you're hooking me right there i go
to the yellow box right there
i'm telling you man
when you [ __ ] okay [ __ ] with slate
was funny all right but when joey
doesn't like somebody
that's even funnier torturing okay all
right all right how about
how about to tell the story about how
you torture my black jack wilson all
right with the guy remember when he
missed we found out that he liked the
cross dress
of course you know someone named
blackjack wilson let me ask you a
question
let me ask your questions
what was the chick with the kid
she said what's her name was the kid's
father
at the comedy store she was dating bob
baker what happened to that bro oh
where is she oh i don't know anything i
haven't heard anything nothing yeah i
was sitting there going and i see the
dude yeah yeah yeah
you're walking around yeah i feel like
saying what happened to him but
why don't maybe the rock closed yeah
that's what i figured yeah
so funny
coco when's when you don't like somebody
folks he'll they'll find out where
they're working and call up as somebody
was complaining i i was at the uh the
nine o'clock show our show started at
seven then it was the seven o'clock show
god [ __ ] and you just be so mad and so
mad and then okay hang up call all right
and then and then like an hour later he
picked the phone back up
and called the guy he hates and he hates
yeah what's going on another hey man not
for nothing but the the club just called
me and asked me if i wanted to come in
and do your week
oh my god they did let me talk to him so
he would make sure that they would talk
to the club and then he's like yeah we
heard some complaints
okay
some complaints then the guy gets scared
hey yo man they already got me at the
[ __ ] airport all right you're gonna
lose your job all right yeah yeah
they're gonna all right hey come pick me
up and i'll have them let you feature
all right you did that twice but the
best of the best you've ever done
is when you used to [ __ ] pete out of the
[ __ ] from the last stop
out of
those [ __ ] out of that [ __ ]
airfare money
for like like i want to say probably 10
15 times
you just beat
beat up
for [ __ ] airline money like hey
rent's tight hey pete yeah fly me down i
need the money now though so here send
me the money i'll buy the ticket i'll be
there i swear to god i'll be there i'll
be there no no
i was burying [ __ ] for a while
that was your boy in beaumont well you
could say
you got joey this weekend and you're
like i don't think so
you started torturing my wife
i saw joey at the store last night
bulma was not
airport waiting on a continental flight
all right and uh and you're like no and
he's like joey you're here and he's
leaving messages and joe you can hear
baggage from phoenix is on carousel
three carousel three for phoenix all
right and you can hear this and then
that's what made you laugh you're like
robbie mate listen to this
and we're in my apartment smoking weed
it's [ __ ] you're supposed to be at
the laptop you [ __ ] them i beat them out
of 800. listen to this and when you keep
on hearing the baggage on the carousel
hey
hey i'm here
that's a 60 mile [ __ ] trip and then
when you get the hobby i'm like no
oh [ __ ] so where are you right now wait
a second let me call you back in five
minutes
that's it you'll never hear from me
again you'll be down
you'll be
you're telling me dude in my room we
were in my kitchen table and you know
about me you know what this is and i go
what it's pete driving home away from
the airport
because i ain't that good
oh my god
i sent them to three different airports
because houston really got three
airports they got another one that you
go all the way down that's a small
airport yeah and if you get a ticket on
like a cheap [ __ ] puerto rican ticket
service yeah it's 8 45 a.m and they
won't tell you you got to get all the
way down at 8 45 again and they put you
on additional
let me tell you something it's like
putting you on a plane from hollywood to
north hollywood making you get off oh no
oh yeah
yeah shuttle
brutal
brutal
oh coco when you [ __ ] get into people
and you don't even you you play nice
like like not for nothing
then clinton's should be calling you and
giving you putin's like all you need is
his phone number
all right
if we find out how much he [ __ ] got
into him it's like
f
[ __ ] a fat guy on a bed or a oh
[ __ ] cyber attacking let's let coco
have like a number and
i was telling my old drug dealer which
one
i mean like wood street no not hollywood
oh okay we always talk we talk once a
month
but we talk extra heavy around the super
bowl
and we're both talking talking talking
and he gets off the phone and
whatever new england wins i call him
back and we're talking
and that morning i wake up and i'm
thinking about it i'm like how many
years do i know this [ __ ]
this relationship started by him getting
beat up and me giving him my gun
i stole from 1440. there was a piece
that was there
an old piece in an apartment
it was a 38 and and i and i
yeah it was a top shelf and i gave that
to them for protection plus that bought
me like 10 bags of blow from you know
what i'm saying yeah just to keep me
alive i gave you that gun give me a
couple [ __ ] bundles here
yeah
that relationship's been on since 19
i've been buying i was buying coke from
them
but now we've been friends since
yeah damn near 97. wow that's how long i
know those brothers from yeah so 97 i
was [ __ ] with that man and i'm still
friends with them today
and what i did to them
i used to torture him oh yeah i used to
tell him come to the store hurry up
make jaggers here
james brown is here
listen if they snort coke they're here
get on down here [ __ ] i'm laying
down not for nothing you also had a lot
of credibility because you also knew
bobby [ __ ] brown and whitney houston
all right all right and that's legit
that was no no but they never came to
the store no no no but they i kept that
completely
nobody even knew even existed but it was
funny how that's how i would get this
particular guy down there because i
always owed him a thousand bucks yeah he
going why am i gonna come down here you
owe me money you got my money [ __ ] no i
got you i got a 15 check for you but i'm
telling you to come down here
because you could sell a [ __ ] ounce
down here everybody's here rick james is
here rick james is dead he's here i'm
telling you
i just saw him he's looking for [ __ ]
packages
so i would make him go down there i
wouldn't make him go down look at poorly
a little
i would make him go down there
and he would go where's all the drug
deals where's everybody i go they just
they just left but while i got you here
give me a 60.
[ __ ] i know you're gonna trick
me you know many times i did that to him
are you serious you would bring a uh
i would make him come down at one in the
morning and tell him at least i answered
with a [ __ ]
stack of hundreds stack of hundreds two
[ __ ] who are hungry even if i just
held on to that one skinny dude just
give him a 20 yeah bro
a 20 that's better than nothing let me
get let me hold on to that 60 till
tomorrow you know what i'm saying i got
[ __ ] happening the producers call them
tomorrow
i gotta go i gotta go i gotta go to the
laundry room at 14 40.
wait for the mailman to come this [ __ ]
doug tell lee that we knew the mailman
by first name the filipino oh my god
yeah we were skipping them
gambling we're out there okay we're
outside of our apartment conference he
would tell me if i had a check yeah like
an hour before he go i gotta i have
check
and they come back that meant party time
lately
you heard the [ __ ] guy
now lee at that time it could have been
a check for three dollars
or it could have been a check for three
thousand dollars nobody knew but in my
mind it was the three thousand dollars
sit tightly you're gonna learn something
right here what and i would just
36 dollars jesus christ yeah i'm gonna
fall away away from three g's
i will make it work let me cash this
check at the wilcox yeah that means they
take a dollar fifty i still got 23 in
chains i can still stop stop by my
buddies get a 20 spot i still got three
dollars for gump that's better than you
who's better than a two dollar for a tip
for water at the campus though hey man
yeah man
we would sit up we knew that guy
so well i mean we'd just be sitting out
there pimpy would be playing around and
uh this was way before pimping
was it before pippy yeah well no we
still knew that we knew the mailman
listen i got mail there until 2005. what
yeah easy when did you move out
when did he move in
[ __ ] when he moved in
he just opened the door can i stay here
yes boom that was what it was on the
road whoever didn't come home yeah
the door was open there was always a
secret a cigarette something something
was going to happen in that [ __ ]
building it was what kept us alive
for two or three years
bro bro we we
i'm sorry bro i'm just i'm losing it
right now what happened though no
you're fine
okay what did you see nothing nothing it
just what did you hear look at that
[Music]
you two need to remake cranky anchors
listen it's 2017. oh my gosh this has to
become a show soon three dudes just
taking care of hillary
and topics coming up and you just die in
the smoke tell me about that
somebody'll buy that even at three in
the morning we'll start at three in the
morning nobody's not no advertising no
[ __ ] zero this is yeah this is agreement
man
we can buy we can buy if we did a season
of these we could pull a buyer and allen
we can put it out who's going to last a
season of these things are you kidding
me
listen we'll shoot them all in three
days yeah but you shouldn't go for three
days after three days we'll take it to a
hotel room a hospital
with your
venus
you're not gonna take me anywhere you're
gonna wait we'll go over those we'll get
some sandwiches
don't leave me but you're gonna take me
here i'm not gonna go to the hotel i'm
not gonna take it to a hotel i'm gonna
get to the hospital
i can't believe you still go see a
little fourth thing
and you should be ashamed
i can't help it
but it's i mean leah is like our mascot
man it's like what we always needed
i don't want them [ __ ] seeing things
this [ __ ] give me the paperwork what do
you mean you don't want me seeing things
no i don't need to just say things oh my
god do you want me to read some of this
[ __ ] read it all right we're gonna go to
jail do not say nothing during this one
i don't believe in people i love them
number one
the best ever i love them to death
always
hellotushy.com listen
nobody talk nobody ever talks about
washing your little muffler right
everybody talks about slinging dick and
getting gonorrhea and using condoms
nobody ever says you know what i watched
my muffler so [ __ ] good last night
it was tremendous pick it up late no one
says that anymore
make america great again make america
great again
and this is it hello she's trying to do
that hello tushy everything is [ __ ] a
sense of humor
it's marketing everybody loves their
[ __ ] to be clean how many times have
you scratched your [ __ ] sniffed it
and said jesus christ why do i live with
myself every day who comes out of my ass
i can do that right now oh i know for a
fact i can't even imagine what your
little muffler you took a shower like 7
30. you've been walking around raw ass
since 7 30. you took two shits you ain't
hummus
you haven't bathed it's 10 o'clock you
know what your [ __ ] smells like right
now
it smells like heartbeats that's what
that's
that's that's that's what they do like
if right now if you were walking down
the street by yourself walking through a
bus stop a van would pull over they'd be
like these incognito guys and they rip
you in and they cut your ass whole lot
and they have like an rb stick around
them awesome elevators told ralphie not
to say anything they probably roughly
relax
no i'm thinking this is a great thing
for women to [ __ ] buy their guy
because they're good hey it's february
you're going to have to suck some dicks
so you might as well have a clean
[ __ ] down there they got a [ __ ]
valentine's day thing really buy two
shoes that's what you need buy two hello
tushies and get free shipping
well bang it out he gets a clean muffler
and mama gets a clean muffler because
mama's muffler doesn't need to get clean
it's the monkoi that's the one but again
i don't want it too clean just a little
bit of water like just a little bit of
spit in there i don't want you to get
the [ __ ] fungi out of nothing like
that i want that intact you know what
i'm saying i want you for who you are
your dirty animal and with hello tricia
you have that option that's it that's
right and it's portable and it's a
60-day money-back guarantee no what is
it what is it a day money back guarantee
i don't even know you don't need it i
think it's 30 60 who cares 60 90 it
don't matter this thing you own these
money if it's lasted [ __ ] four months
in my house with the size of my ass and
the size of my [ __ ] and the amount of
water it takes to wash that little brown
muffler it'll do wonders for your little
tushy listen lee spit it out [ __ ]
yes
ghettohellotushy.com right now and press
in church
c-h-u-r-c-h
and get well 10 off and if you're the
two of them you get free shipping boom
right to the [ __ ] house and your
muffler's clean you can feel confident
you won't get that stink coming out of
your back you know i'm saying you can
wear shorts again it's a different
experience
hellotushy.com go to hellotushy.com
right now
get a [ __ ] bidet
but hit it hello calm slash church all
right boom get 10 off two of them for
valentine's day special listen maybe
there's somebody at work give a look at
somebody though you know what
i guarantee that guy's [ __ ] smells
like 10 dead feet okay
that guy there just put it in this chair
for happy valentine's day like he
doesn't have a valentine you and i both
know this
buy one for him go to hellotushy.com
right now and press in church bam and
get your
10 off that's right hellotushi.com
right now
i want to thank hellotushy.com
i want to thank ralphie may i want to
thank the flying jew this was a hell of
a podcast hello podcast i'm starting to
see things too you know
i gotta take two steps to the ring get
out of this [ __ ] right here
it's been a hell of a night i love you
stay black
[Music]
[Music]
me
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you